[Music]
on this wednesday night who's leading
the so-called freedom convoy
with borders blocked and protesters
holding steady what's next for the
organizers of these disruptive protests
we need to focus on the goal
of removing the mandates
removing the passport kids on the front
line we're not going to put our child in
that kind of jeopardy ever police raise
concerns over children living in some of
the trucks parked near parliament hill
plus living with covid as more provinces
lift public health restrictions what
does the science say
and the medals mount canada's latest
triumphs at the beijing olympic
global games with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are continuing to watch the
disruptions caused by protests in this
country and looking more deeply at the
organizers this is the ambassador bridge
from detroit to windsor traffic from the
us to canada remains blocked by trucks
and protesters demanding freedom
disrupting supply lines and businesses
that employ thousands of people forcing
truckers and others to take long detours
that has led to a backlog at a second
border crossing near sarnia we'll have
more on that in just a moment the former
u.s ambassador to canada bruce heyman
tweeted this today
the protests in ottawa canada and the
ambassador bridge are less and less
about vaccines and more and more about
political extremism and desires to
disrupt the canadian government and
economy done with external radical
influences and money
there is a lot to dissect about these
protests and there are a range of
grievances one of the main organizers
canada unity asked people to sign this
memorandum of understanding which it
planned to give to the senate and the
governor general compelling them to drop
public health measures or dissolve the
government that is undemocratic and
unconstitutional now the group says that
does not reflect the spirit and intent
of the convoy and it is withdrawn the
memorandum of understanding to avoid
what it calls any unintended
interpretations
so what are the intentions of the
organizers and what are their next moves
ross lord has our top story tonight from
ottawa
[Music]
protesters and their supporters are
still squeezing in signatures on this
vehicle among them retired military
member adam rickman he says he's tired
of pandemic restrictions i'm not into
wearing masks and restricting my
breathing i'm not into having forced
needles but others warn protest
supporters should be careful about what
they're signing up for they say the
occupation is about much more than masks
or distancing they say it's part of a
larger plan that threatens democracy we
see it
all over uh all over the western world
this
emboldening of far-right extremist
actors
um and
we
are not immune to it here in canada what
we share right now
is a blossoming autocratic threat on the
north american continent it is more
advanced in the united states
but you just saw the first petals bloom
in canada and it won't be the last of it
it's unclear what the hierarchy looks
like behind the so-called freedom convoy
if there is a hierarchy among the key
catalysts is tamara leach her previous
campaigns include promoting the wexit
party our departure will be based on the
prime minister doing what is right pat
king supported wexit 2 he's now a vocal
convoy organizer who calls himself an
investigative journalist wait till the
real bullets start flying but one of the
main speakers at a recent news
conference was tom marazzo a former
military engineer he led the call for
overthrowing the federal government
during the occupation the more of us
there are
the better it is for all of us marazzo
is no longer named as a spokesperson for
the convoy but it's hard to confirm who
is global news reached out to purported
communications contacts but got no reply
organizers of a news conference
wednesday did not invite global news and
refused to admit other media along with
new questions about who's organizing the
occupation there are shifting political
positions on ending it i said it's time
to go now
time to get back to work a different
tone from conservative mp kevin waugh
who was posing with protesters when the
convoy first arrived as for its
phenomenal ability to raise money online
the federal government says it's
investigating back at street level there
are smaller gestures aimed at reclaiming
the city for its residents who've been
subjected to around-the-clock noise
pollution verbal harassment public
urination and street blockades convoy
organizers should just sort of be
confronted with that reality after
waiting more than a week to take action
ottawa police are putting protesters on
notice their trucks could be seized if
they continue blocking streets illegally
on day 13 a signal this occupation might
be closer to coming to a head
ross lord global news ottawa
the ceo of canada's largest trucking
conglomerate says the cross-border
vaccine mandate for truckers which is in
place in canada and the united states is
not an issue at all for his company
alebadar the chief executive of tfi
international inc points out the
majority of truckers in canada are
vaccinated and that his cross-border
truckers who have chosen not to be
vaccinated have been reassigned to
canadian routes
the blockade by protesters at north
america's busiest land border is having
an impact on supply chains the
ambassador bridge between windsor and
detroit is blocked to u.s traffic coming
to canada and forcing truckers and
others who don't support it to take long
detours sean o'shea reports
like a backup goalie in hockey the
bluewater bridge has suddenly been
called into action because a couple of
hours away in windsor protesters are
still not letting trucks cross the much
larger ambassador bridge into canada
this man who calls himself greg defends
the ongoing blockade why do i think i
have the right why does any protester
think he has the right to do anything
for three days shipments have been
diverted and slowed down frustrating
many driving those delayed rigs and
infuriating industries that count on
speedy deliveries it's a huge challenge
for all the industries involved for all
the employees involved and of course for
you know just the flow of goods to final
citizens to consumers it's it's just um
it's staggering actually the auto
industry is especially dependent on
those shipments and thousands of jobs it
is breathlessly stupid
for a group that wants to
inspire
people to join their movement
to put those same people out of work and
now and here we are formally requesting
additional resources windsor's mayor is
asking for federal and provincial help
including more police officers is there
a timeline to get this resolved
again today tomorrow situation unfolds
we're not going to discuss our
operational plans public safety is the
number one priority and we're looking to
restore traffic flow in the area as
pressure to shut down this protest and
reopen the bridge to incoming trucks
intensifies such action may inflame the
situation
and certainly cause more folks to come
here and add to the protest and we don't
want to risk additional conflict back at
the protest i asked greg about that if
they decide to uh to break this up what
are you guys going to do
there'll be some resistance just like
black lives matter resists nothing's
likely to change in windsor until that
city gets the support it's looking for
near here there was a brief protest but
they moved on the unofficial concern a
second block bridge because as difficult
as this situation is that would be
significantly worse
donna
all right sean o'shea in point edward
ontario thank you well ottawa remains
under a state of emergency the police
set again today it's time for the
protesters to go home the deputy police
chief describes the remaining protesters
as highly determined and volatile they
estimate about a quarter of the 400
vehicles have children inside them and
officers have concerns about their
well-being abigail beeman spoke to some
of the children's parents
this trucker family has been parked in
ottawa for 13 days with their
five-year-old there's not a parent down
here that would jeopardize the safety or
the health of their child
we brought them down here so that they
can be proud of the moment kathleen
callahan says it's sad police are now
working with the children's aid society
over concerns about safety the risk of
carbon monoxide and fumes the noise
levels concerned about cold we're
concerned about access to sanitation
of the ability to shower um there's a
multitude of concerns we've had a ton of
support from a lot of the ottawa
residents who have opened their homes
for showers using their bathrooms
so you know it's not like we're locked
in these trucks i think it's disgusting
that they would take the chance of
traumatizing the children with cas there
was no media availability with police
wednesday and the children's aid society
declined multiple interview requests in
a joint statement the organization said
police would report any potential
dangers they observe to the cas and that
there have been ongoing reports around
welfare concerns but the cas wouldn't
respond to a number of questions by
deadline including how many calls
they've received what type of concerns
they're looking at and whether they'd
consider removing any children from here
we've seen no indication of anything
unsafe at all i mean the only things
we've seen that say it's unsafe are
reports from legacy media these cabins
are designed to be slept in while
vehicles are running
so i mean at this point it seems like
they're trying to pull straws and
anything they can to try and
add scare tactics
parents global news spoke to say they
want to teach their children about
protests and call for change she has no
idea what a birthday party is
family gathering
if she has a doctor's appointment we
can't even go in as a family but this
family says if police were to move in in
some kind of raid they would leave
immediately for the sake of their
daughter's safety
abigail beeman global news ottawa
give send go which calls itself a
christian crowdfunding site is the new
home for the so-called freedom convoys
fundraising campaign after gofundme shut
down fundraising for the group nearly
eight million dollars u.s has been
raised on give sand go the goal is 16
million the largest single donation so
far is 215 000
there's not a lot of transparency about
who is donating campaign organizers say
they'll ensure the money goes to aid and
legal support for truckers and their
families gofundme shut down the convoy's
donation page on friday claiming it
violated the site's terms prohibiting
content supporting violence gibbs sango
says it does not condone violence in any
form the site was blocked last year
after it was used to raise money for
people involved in the attempted
insurgency at the u.s capitol well u.s
lawmakers are threatening to investigate
gofundme for shutting down the
fundraising for the group texas senator
ted cruz is accusing it of effectively
trying to steal the 10 million dollars
raised the fundraiser has gained support
from lots of people in groups outside
canada and now the us is bracing for a
potential nationwide convoy of its own
jackson prosko looks at the false
information fueling much of that support
with the maple leaf leading the way
copycat convoys rolled out across new
zealand
and in europe where french truck drivers
are headed to brussels
they have the courage to do what the
canadians have done before us said this
supporter
will we need our own trucker rally to
end all of this insanity once and for
all
in the u.s conservative media have taken
up the cause the truckers of the world
are uniting with breathless coverage of
the ottawa protest channels like fox
news and newsmax seem to be urging
americans into the streets the folks
here in charge in america don't want us
getting crazy ideas
about standing up for our freedoms in
the same way that is happening right now
in canada
the spread of this canadian contagion is
being fueled by misinformation there are
false claims circulating online that
exaggerate the size and success of the
ottawa protest all meant to inspire
others i do think that a lot of what
what we see in terms of attempts to
organize something are just kind of
people who are just putting it out there
and seeing if somebody will bite
you know i think that should not be
overlooked based on what's happening in
canada plans are now in the works for an
american version of the convoy it would
arrive here in washington on march 1
with the goal of disrupting president
biden's trip to the capitol to deliver
his state of the union address
researchers warn opportunists around the
world are now trying to figure out how
to go bigger than the canadians i think
they would love to see something that
had a significant destructive effect
it leaves little doubt the global
movement will continue to spread
inspired by a small well-organized and
well-funded operation that has shown how
easily it can cause disruption
jackson prosko global news
washington rcmp and alberta are aiming
to move protesters away from the canada
u.s border crossing in the town of coots
that blockade has disrupted cross-border
traffic for 12 days and the province's
move to ease public health restrictions
appears to have done little to satisfy
people alberta dropped its proof of
vaccination requirement today
saskatchewan plans to do the same later
this week everyone is tired of public
health restrictions and no government
has said they intend to keep them in
place forever as heather urex west
reports when to do it and why is the
subject of hot debate
just a couple of hours after alberta's
premier announced plans to end the
province's proof of vaccine program and
other culvert restrictions protesters at
the kutz border crossing made it clear
they were not satisfied overall it's
disappointing
yeah there was some good that come out
of it but not even not even a 10 percent
by 8 o'clock tuesday access to the busy
crossing was blocked again but as
protesters call for the lifting of even
more coveted restrictions others in
alberta fear these changes are happening
too soon i think there's two components
with one i think it's sending the wrong
message covet is far from over
and secondly our healthcare system is
still under severe stress
the reality is across alberta and
saskatchewan the number of people in
hospital with covid is near an all-time
high and the number of people in alberta
who have received a booster dose is less
than 40 percent
it's why these edmonton parents aren't
sure how they feel about in-school mask
mandates lifting next week i'm kind of
mixed because
personally i think they serve a purpose
i'm very concerned about this
because
they're little and i don't want them to
be sick
restaurant owners are unhappy too
because while alberta is ending its
proof of vaccine program also known as
the rep
other rules like the 11 o'clock end to
liquor sales will remain the alberta
hospitality association says it doesn't
make sense we've been very clear that
if anything step process wise the
restriction should be lifted
and maybe our ap stays in place
after two years of restrictions convoy
protesters aren't the only ones who want
things back to normal alberta and
saskatchewan are now forging a path
but it's not without risk
heather urex west global news calgary
the risk and rewards of lifting pandemic
measures coming up when is the right
time experts weigh in on the possible
risks of moving too fast plus alberta's
premier apologizes for comments he made
about the unvaccinated
alberta premier jason kenney has
apologized for comparing attitudes
towards unvaccinated people to the
stigma people with aids and hiv faced in
the 1980s kenny tweeted today i made an
inappropriate analogy to the
stigmatization of people with aids i was
wrong to do so and apologize without
reservation this is what he said
yesterday while announcing his plan to
lift most public health restrictions
including proof of vaccination
in a way it kind of reminds me of the
attitudes
that circulated
in north america in the mid 1980s about
people with hiv aids
that there's this notion that they they
had to be kind of
distanced
for health reasons
that quickly led to a backlash kenny has
faced widespread criticism for his
political history with the gay community
in 1989 he helped overturn a spousal law
in san francisco that permitted gay men
to visit their dying partners in the
hospital during the aids pandemic
i've helped to lead a uh
ultimately successful initiative
petition which led to a referendum which
overturned the first gay
spousal law in north america
that video of kenny explaining his role
surfaced in 2019 before he was elected
premier
ahead as province's lift restrictions
what does the science tell us
everyone wants public health
restrictions to be lifted and for life
to return to normal we know what's
happened though when they've been lifted
too soon coveted cases and
hospitalizations have soared
now vaccination levels are higher than
they've ever been jamie morocco looks at
what's being weighed as these decisions
are made
kristy dickinson is immunocompromised
and soon she'll have to navigate how to
stay healthy in a world without coven 19
restrictions i would hope that as we
look at reopening
that we can do so you know in a in a
thoughtful um
you know step-by-step way in ontario
where dickinson lives the province is
moving forward with a phased reopening
plan making it easier for her to adjust
quebec and prince edward island have
also laid out strategies to lift public
health measures over the course of the
next month or so but saskatchewan and
alberta are ripping the restrictions
band-aid right off i think it's a
political decision but
you know science-based decisions you
know often through the pandemic have not
sort of looked at the economic issues so
you kind of have to balance the two
but decision makers have to strike that
balance this epidemiologist says with
local evidence in mind
hospital rates icu rates wastewater
rates if they're going down and they
have been for the last three weeks then
we can look forward to to taking a few
more steps prairie hospitalizations have
shown a slight decline but have not
consistently dipped if
we remove mass mandates if we remove
vaccine passports if we remove gathering
limits there's no reason to think that
numbers won't just go up one of the
first countries to choose to live with
covid denmark is now experiencing a
record number of hospitalizations and
although icu numbers remain low covades
remain about the same as they did last
year the spike wasn't unexpected but
canada's healthcare system is more
fragile but let's try and keep the
increase to a speed bump
level
not another cliff face of an increase we
want to control it dickinson worries
another wave means she won't be able to
access in-person care
that's a really
important
aspect of the reopening for me and for
so many others who have had their health
sidelined because of the pandemic jamie
morocco global news toronto
statistics canada has released data from
the latest census and it shows how fast
canada's population is growing our
population reached nearly 37 million
last year that's a 5.2 percent increase
over five years the fastest growth rate
of any g7 country though canada saw its
lowest growth rate in a century in 2020
just 0.4 percent despite related
limitations immigrants helped fuel the
population boost
next team canada speeds and soars its
way to the metal podium again
canada has upped its metal hall to eight
on day five of the winter olympics in
beijing stephen dubois won silver in the
men's 1500 meter short track event the
24 year old olympic rookie is from
quebec
and canada is bringing home another
bronze marietta o'dine finished third in
women's snowboard cross this is also her
olympic debut and canada's first podium
finish in the event since the 2014 sochi
games we could get another medal in team
figure skating the final results are
still in doubt though two days after the
competition no one has been awarded
medals just flowers the ioc is blaming
the hold up on legal issues there are
few details but officials have confirmed
medal winners are involved in the case
canada placed fourth in the event russia
finished first the us second and japan
third
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is belle isle bay near
kingston new brunswick thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you